I have with me this afternoon John White
who is the State Superintendent of
Education for the state of Louisiana he
was the deputy Chancellor for the New
York City school system so he's had a
lot of experience with a broad range of
organizations and positions in education
and currently he's the chair of the
Chiefs for change in organization of
state chief officers who are committed
to reform in American education and I'm
very pleased to have the opportunity to
talk with him today about the amazing
developments that have been occurring in
Louisiana Louisiana has always been a
low-performing state but in recent years
under John White's leadership this state
has made more progress than any other
state in the United States according to
the National Assessment of Educational
Progress and it all starts perhaps
with Katrina the great hurricane in New
Orleans because that washed away the
pre-existing school system so John
that's what I'd like to really ask you
about how did it happen that a new
school system was built out of shall I
say the ashes for at least the mud
sludge of the Katrina storm great great
tragedy because we call it a man-made
tragedy in New Orleans but prior to
Katrina New Orleans by any measure was
the lowest performing urban school
system in the country it was the second
lowest performing school system and the
second lowest performing state in
America when you have to vacate your
entire city for weeks and months and
sometimes even years for many of our
people you have no students when you
have no students you have no revenue for
a school board and when that happened
the school board in New Orleans in 2005
tragically severed its contract with its
teachers
and the state stepped in and said well
we will then take over the governance of
every school in New Orleans which is
struggling academically and that was
nearly 90 percent of the schools over
time the state transitioned those
schools from being run by the state to
being operated by independent charter
school organizations that took many many
years but it took a decade and now we
are where we are with a system that is
almost exclusively independent charter
schools well actually you had a little
help I think that's what I've heard and
maybe you could tell me where there's
some outside resources that became
available simply because the tragedy
captured national attention and the
Foundation's come in question I mean New
Orleans is a city that is at the heart
of the American identity it's a city
that whenever you mentioned people have
smiles across their faces and it's also
a city of great poverty and
philanthropic interests know that from
across the country as well as from
within Louisiana also people in a range
of issues from blight and urban
development issues all the way to
education and health issues came to
Louisiana I count myself as one of them
to help with what I think of as a
reformation but not just of a school
system since a storm really of tragedies
that have befallen low-income people in
Louisiana and in the south for centuries
and that's what our project is about but
no question about it both people from
the inside and people from the outside
were part of this isn't young people
came to didn't they didn't young
teachers from around the country feel it
was sort of their moral obligation to go
to New Orleans and help out during this
time of stress yeah I think there was a
missionary feel to it certainly I view
it as a moral calling at the same time
it also gave rise to old generation of
New Orleanians who had as is the case in
New York or anywhere else existed within
a school board establishment that's very
hard to be creative within and very hard
to be upwardly mobile in you know so
there are a lot of veteran New Orleans
educators who are now able to run
schools that they always wanted to run
and they're able to do it in a charter
school system where they work for a
volunteer board rather than for an
elected board and serpent's a lot of
internal energy as well as bringing in
external energy yeah no question about
it and and you know over the last ten
years
we've been finding our way to how do you
give life to local voices how do you
recruit the right outside voices and how
when you recruit outside voices do you
make sure that the things that are
important to us in New Orleans music for
example in the arts incredibly important
to the identity of people in New Orleans
and to their upbringing how do you make
sure that you never lose those things
even when you have outside talent and
the federal government helped with some
building of schools was that part of the
part of the assets doesn't were able to
work without heard you know every child
now is in a renovated or a fully
reconstructed building you know some
amazing buildings but the school where
Ruby Bridges went to school in New
Orleans we have totally rebuilt
preserved the facade and preserved her
classroom and it's amazing the resources
that came into New Orleans after that
great tragedy and of course those are
opportunities for the next generation of
kids as much as there were tragedies for
many of the kids who were there we also
benefited from an investment innovation
at the federal government the Obama
administration rather than the Bush
administration in this case made to grow
high performing charter organizations
and you know so we've done some good
things we've certainly got had a lot of
help along the way it's not resources
that every city has at their disposal
but it's also fair to say the principles
of it independent schools recruiting
talent those are things that anybody can
do well is there any good evidence that
all of this has paid off that students
are actually learning more today than
they had been in the days before all of
this renovation took place one of the
things were also blessed with is it
wasn't just educators but it was
political scientists and economists who
came to Louisiana they wanted to study
this stuff too in fact Tulane has
started a center run by an economist
named Doug Harris and economists got
together and studied the effects in
multiple ways of what's happened in
Louisiana and in New Orleans
specifically and had concluded that
statistically no school system that
those researchers are aware of has
demonstrated the effect on student
achievement in such a short period of
time than having a while in schools I do
want to be clear though we have a long
long way to go you know New Orleans has
gone from the bottom of the state in
Louisiana to around the median in the
state of Louisiana which given its
poverty rate another thing
incredible thing but it's not nearly at
the top of our state and our state still
performs relatively low in the national
ranking so we have a long long way to go
well Louisiana is also enacted a school
voucher program so it's a statewide
school voucher program I think it has
its component in New Orleans but
elsewhere throughout the state how has
that worked out so it's shown a lot of
good positive effects it's shown
positive effects in terms of greater
integration of schools it's shown
positive effects in terms of parent
approval it's begun to show positive
effects in initial research in terms of
the effect of having greater levels of
competition so kids in other schools in
proximity to the voucher schools are
doing well and we'll have research
coming out soon that I think will
demonstrate that the voucher schools
right now are performing on a par with
schools in the rest of the system that
said you know for me it's not about
whether it's a private school a charter
school or a traditional public school it
just is it a good school my viewers we
should measure them all give parents
access to all of them and and that the
system will be better for parents having
that choice provided that we can
validate that there's good work going on
in their schools well the overall system
in Louisiana is moving forward what do
you attribute that to it's a simple
formula you know this stuff is not is
not rocket science but it's actually
having access to early childhood
education it's having benchmark
standards and assessments in curriculum
and curriculum matters I have to say
that it's having prepared teachers who
are prepared in the classroom not in the
ivory tower a pathway to prosperity for
every graduate and revitalizing our
career technical education system and
then finally not being afraid to
intervene you know when things are
really going off the rails and typically
in our country that affects low-income
kids of color you can't be afraid to
intervene and so we're looking at Baton
Rouge and doing work in Shreveport and
other cities where there are high
concentrations of struggling schools and
low-income neighborhoods that's not
something that we can tolerate and you
have to be willing to do something about
it so you're the head of keep for change
achieves for change which is trying to
introduce reforms throughout the country
working together with other people who
are like you the head of the educational
system in that stage so how can you
export
you're learning in Louisiana how does it
work when you are working with an
organization like that
well Chase for change is a group of
there's a handful of us who are States
Chiefs in Mississippi New Mexico Nevada
Massachusetts the Washington DC State
Superintendent so we've got a good mix
of State Chiefs we've also got district
Chiefs and you know you in our system
and the fragmented American education
system you have to have both on boards
you can't have the state in the district
working consistently at odds with one
another so we have huge district
superintendents that are doing amazing
things from California all the way to
Florida in our group too and you know
where we have formed working groups to
take on what we think are the greatest
challenges coming up one of them is how
should schools be governed in times when
the current governing structure is not
working what should be done and I think
that's an incredibly powerful question
given everything that we've tried that's
worked based on research over the last
10 years under No Child Left Behind and
race to the top but also there's a lot
that hasn't worked and there's a lot of
wasted money and wasted activity and so
that's one example of how we can work
together to say this is what we're
committed to doing together well so let
me be specific about that how about the
New Orleans model where every school is
a school of choice is that something
that should be put into place in other
big cities around the country and we're
experiencing this of course in
Massachusetts as we have this dialogue
that there is a referendum on the ballot
regarding our charter schools a good
thing and the research in Massachusetts
would demonstrate without question that
they are in Louisiana it would
demonstrate without question that there
are and there are other places that our
charter schools have really struggled so
it's not just is an all charter school
system a good thing I mean let's be
honest look at Detroit it's not working
at the scale that it needs to work at it
the quality it needs to work at so can
it be done well yes if there's a plan to
have talent to have accountability to
have the right governance model to offer
options to families and to intervene
when schools don't do well you know if
you have those things in place it can
work and there's research now in
Massachusetts and Louisiana and
elsewhere to demonstrate that it can
work but it's not just charter schools
it's having a plan for who runs them and
what to do
that'll work no magic bullet is going to
solve the problem of embarrassing
occasion no question John this has been
a great opportunity for me to discuss
our schools and where we need to go
thank you very much for joining me today
one for me as well thanks Paul thanks
you